how many girls do you really know that
are really climbing the corporate ladder
I mean you maybe you think you lived in
New York right I did yeah maybe you knew
more of them but most girls
most girls jobs and
jobs are not climbing anything see I
know a lot of girls that are trying that
are trying to compete with men like in
the cities and I grew up with a lot of
them that were like I want to be the
manager I want to be the CEO I want to
be like that's that's a sign that I've
been successful in life and they they
forward having children for a really
long time in order to do that so I think
they exist and they're you know this is
just I'm just saying by and large the
average salary is like 35
000 a year for women so like by and
large women aren't climbing the
corporate ladder like there are some
right maybe like 10 15 but I would say
like by and large it's more just like it
was fun